there are new travel rules today um due
to the omicron variant all international
travelers are now required to take a
covet 19 test within one day of leaving
for the u.s omicron cases have been
confirmed in at least 17 states all of
them are mild as far as we know
there have been no deaths attributed to
the new strain now the emergence of the
omicron variant could make testing for
covett more important than ever before
the biden administration plans more
testing with a focus on expanding access
to at-home tests cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus joins us now
to sort this all out david agus it's
always good to see you let's get right
to it about omicron we've heard about it
less than two weeks now still so much we
don't know as we sit here today what
concerns you most
you know on november 23rd in south
africa the first cases of omicron were
reported and now it is 75 of cases being
reported in south africa so it is a two
to three times more infectious variant
we think or easier to spread than delta
so that's really worrisome there's some
initial indication that it may cause
milder disease
and it looks so younger hospitalizations
but many fewer but that's early and so
we really don't know the
impact clinically of this variant but
we're certainly worried that it spreads
so easily
and when do you think we're going to
know something we have we've had a lot
of we really don't know really don't
know conversation ever since we've heard
about omicron when will we know
something conclusively that we can make
decisions
you know it's a great question there's
no lab test to tell you how much of a
problem a particular variant will cause
the only thing we can do is actually
look at the data of hospitalizations so
what we do know
is that recent vaccination or booster
will protect from serious illness that
data looked pretty good from south
africa and that's somewhat encouraging
what we also know is that prior covet
infection with delta gives little
protection to infection and that's
obviously worrisome because there's a
whole cohort of people in the united
states that had prior delta and said ah
i don't need a vaccine because i'm
protected because i just had the virus
and what we're seeing with with this new
variant is that's not the case so the
good is there were over a million people
who got boosters uh over the last day so
people are lining up and omicron is
pushing people to get boosters and get
vaccinated which is what we need
good now omicron was likely spreading in
the us before these travel bans were put
in place um why was there a delay on
discovering this variant
well you know in the united states we do
testing and then the samples are sent
for genomic sequencing to look at the
rna and to say hey what type of virus is
this what variant is it and there's a
delay um there's just an inherent delay
in how we do it it's not real time and
so it will take a while for us to know
the true extent it is probably in most
parts of the united states at the
present time spreading and what we're
going to see is over the next couple of
weeks it will peak probably beginning of
january to mid-january omicron so really
what we're gonna see is over the next
three four weeks dramatic increase in
the number of cases of omicron and it's
a perfect storm right the weather is
getting colder people are getting
together for the holidays we all have
covid fatigue omicron is here all of
those things together really make it
worrisome
so david on top of that you talk about
people getting together for the holidays
the bite administration plans to expand
at-home testing
you know gail and i were talking about
this a little earlier how confident are
you that these tests are all you might
need if you want to visit for example an
immuno-compromised relative
i take a side before i respond because
it's not that simple but they are
a very powerful weapon in the war on
kova when i have my thanksgiving dinner
um we had everybody who came from the
family we did an antigen test before
they came in so what they do is they're
not like pcr tests that amplify the rna
and so can be really sensitive to pick
up for early covet infection what these
tests do is they look for the presence
of virus so the people who have lots of
virus or symptomatic they're going to
catch and that's very important because
those are the people who are the biggest
spreaders a lot of virus more virus to
spread and so the tests clearly work in
that regard so they're not perfect but
they're a big addition in the united
kingdom they started to do them and they
gave them out free to everybody in the
country and it was pretty dramatic the
number of people that were identified
and then asked to stay home in
quarantine until they tested negative
okay i just worry about people
administering them correctly but that's
a whole other story i wanted to talk to
you about senator bob dole david because
i know you were part of the medical team
what can you tell us about that process
and what can you tell us about him
you know he was an amazing individual
obviously passed away at 98 years of age
from advanced lung cancer but right
after the inauguration i got a call from
the white house who said david will you
help the amazing doctors at walter reed
medical center in the care of senator
dolan of course i said i'd be privileged
every interaction i have with him
whether it be by telephone or in person
was just him telling stories and you
know he has such an amazing history and
is a hero to so many people and
rightfully so for what he did in world
war ii what he did in the service of our
country and in fighting a cancer it was
you know literally just a privilege to
be in the room with him
dr david agus always we appreciate it
thank you very much sir